hi my name is Olivia Newman young I'm a
makeup artist and if you want to see how
to do a bronzed contoured lip today make
sure you stay watching salt and ash now
has to be one of my favorite bronzers
it's not just the traditional powder so
it can be blended into your foundation
really naturally when applying this
focus the color on the parts of your
face the Sun would hit at first like
your forehead cheeks and nose adding
some color over the eyes or so we'll
give them definition once so the liquid
products are applied you can move on to
powder products this road your palates
Amazings as so many different colors in
it today I'm going to use the contour
medium I'm going to apply this under my
cheekbone this will help to make your
cheekbone pop I'm also going to fly a
little bit onto the end of my nose and a
little bit into the sockets of my eyes
just to add a little bit more contour
and definition by adding a little bit of
the contour under your chin it will just
tighten up and define your neck a subtle
blusher with a brown tone like the Estee
Lauder color Envy lovers blush is a
really nice one to add when you're doing
a bronzed look by adding the blush on
just apples of your cheeks it just gives
you a nice rosy color
if you also put the blusher on to your
forehead nose and collarbone this will
add a really natural color as that's
where the Sun will hit you now on to the
fun part I'm gonna add some of this
Becker moon stone highlighter onto the
highs of my cheekbones and just under my
eyebrow this is really gonna make your
cheekbones pop another little tip if you
add it just into the corners of your
eyes it's really gonna make them pop and
it's gonna tie the whole look in
together now with all this shimmer don't
forget to add a little bit of
translucent powder just into your t-zone
and above your lip it's very easy to
overdo the shine last but not least I've
got here Bobbi Brown's lip color and
mulch shimmer this is a wonderful way to
complete any bronzed look thanks so much
for watching if you want to see more
videos like this one make sure you
subscribe to the glamour UK youtube
channel